I want you to read these five situations
and draw Freebody diagrams for each okay
so let me draw the first one for you and
then you can try the rest let this
horizontal line be the top of the table
and the box is placed here the Freebody
diagrams shows all the forces acting on
it first there is the force of gravity
acting on it it will be downwards and
then there is a normal force acting
upwards as the forces are equal and
opposite the box does not move at all it
continues to remain at rest and also
notice that the size of the arrows is
the same the forces are balanced and the
net force is zero now why don't you try
drawing the free body diagram for the
second situation
read it well first thing first the force
of gravity will exist and pull the box
in the downward direction as its placed
on the table there will be an equal and
opposite normal force acting upwards now
we come to what's written a rightward
force makes the Box move across the
table with rightward acceleration the
word acceleration is very very important
here
it means the velocity is changing and
the fact that the velocity is changing
implies that the forces on the Box are
unbalanced the upward and the downward
forces let each other off what about the
leftward and the rightward forces now
because there is a rightward apply force
we show an arrow towards the right will
there be any leftward force on the box
as we've been asked to ignore air
resistance it will only be the force of
friction acting towards the left and
because the box is accelerating towards
the right it means that the force of
friction is lesser in magnitude than the
applied force towards the right and
hence the size of the arrow of the
applied force is bigger than that of the
frictional force the third situation is
extremely interesting try making a free
body diagram
it says that the box is moving at a
constant velocity towards the right in
any case there will be the gravitational
and normal forces acting on the box but
this kind the applied force and the
frictional force will be of the same in
magnitude
hence the size of these two arrows will
be the same as the net force is zero the
body will continue to move at that
constant velocity and don't forget we've
been asked to ignore air resistance here
now would you like to try drawing the
free body diagrams for the fourth and
the fifth situations in the fourth case
let us first discuss the forces that are
acting on the skydiver there will be the
force of gravity which is pulling the
skydiver down as there is no table or
ground the novel force will not exist
and there's no applied force on the
skydiver either but as the skydiver is
falling at a constant velocity it
implies that the net force must be zero
which is the force that will net the
force of gravity yes it will be the air
resistance as the velocity is constant
it implies that the magnitudes of these
two forces are equal this is the free
body diagram of the fourth situation I
want you to get the fist one right now
this is how it will look as it's
free-falling
it means it's accelerating so the
magnitude of the gravitational force
will be more than the magnitude of the
air resistance force with this you've
understood the basics of forces to know
more do watch our other videos
you
[Music]